walk you out to this video playing Carol
zero from Spain let's see a ruin Italian
game know get the room maybe get them
classical she go in here yep at least I
know what's going on here yeah this is
some line that I really have played lots
of times the capture my ad this recently
did I did I play this against the same
guy possible what's this Honey game
where I was able to play 94 that's very
very similar this is the same position I
think it's the same position come on it
worked once yep maybe it's working for a
second time okay so different move this
time if i take here with the bishop and
then played III he probably needs to
give the piece back right well let I
let's do that come on not again get in
big time time travel yeah I don't think
he can play Bishop be one I mean this
this looks terrible he probably needs to
to play am Bishop d3 okay so much for
this looks terrible okay if I take with
the rook that looks like and it looks
shaky of it with Nyjah phone booth like
that but not G 4 I can take this made on
h2 and edge one okay so i can probably
take i hope i didn't calculate this
wrong okay the bishop we're here to see
three maybe maybe i should have played
Bishop before this would have been
interesting but the main point is not
that i want to promote the pawns quickly
it so that the pawns just hamper his
pieces it's um it's no i'm not something
that I need to prove very quickly I have
higher phone sometime maybe even rookie
five here okay fine well why not I mean
how does he coordinated species I don't
don't see it no this is always trying to
coordinate them maybe successfully but
it's still not great on a two
yeah I probably didn't play the best
possible continuation here I still feel
this should be something maybe it's not
great but this is some compensation
you know I don't know maybe just bishops
III
yeah I don't have Bishop deform
hmm now that's really itís it's not
that's not good at all check my back
rank is a problem and he threatening to
take on f6 mmm now that's not good not
good at all 95 million okay I have this
that if I if I don't know my back rank
you know a queen dee 5 is very close to
working group create it's not not not
not yet but it's shaky threatening to
take them I mean this is a positional
threat I had a three years hanging some
he needs to react somehow I just wonder
what I'm doing if you just place
boishakhi to
hmm yeah i don't know i would love to
make some some look for my king but
every porn movies a weakness like age
six is just running right into
sacrificial ideas
there should be five percent abisha
smooth but maybe a good one yeah yeah
wow really check this probe he wasn't
the best the best that he could do but
still it's not not an easy win I don't
at least I don't see you win how to make
progress maybe bishop p.m. exchange it
hmm maybe I can take age five okay but I
can take e 58 we def to or something
he's never going to to to to to win this
with the porn on d 2i but he's got
Bishop be one at some stage 2 to get
this fisherman to play oh it's just just
tell attacking him wow I overlooked that
shoot no no no no aah come on I dude i
cannot i cannot give it away my pong
okay I cannot go see cannot do this and
he's got Bishop be one coming
I don't have time and you took need to
move now three pawns no mouse slip I
wanted to go to a 65 of course you know
I don't know what this is before it was
probably very good for me check the
pawns are very dangerous I'm not sure
what they are now I've got their mouths
lip manchaca sure it's still winning for
black check
ah what resigned yeah no idea what was
going on just just a big big fight I was
probably lost them somewhere around here
it's erm it's very very tricky to play I
mean I really think I have compensation
but I think you could could spend a long
time to analyze the various
possibilities here oh here mr. windy two
wins in suddenly and very easy ahh blah
check here d 2 man this is very easy
overloading the rook winning the peace I
missed that okay TM yeah Bishop takes us
winning okay very clearly winning Bishop
takes if takes T 2 and then night takes
now on even that one check yeah it's
completely winning yeah I'm stand and
letting so many good possibilities slip
at the moment Queen have two wins okay
we got into the Zen game and this was
really excited ridiculous mal slip I
need to go here of course winning a
temple I after I don't know what this is
I mean the three points are really
dangerous even if he wins the juice g6
born and stuff it's it's just check it's
just very very dangerous with the pawns
you know the constants wide it's winning
but this is for humans this is not to
not that that's easy but should be eight
no wins yeah of course a form if I
cannot play a for check yeah and this
losses
no the apron is promoting yeah this is
murderous to play with with little time
on the clock I just was the lucky a
player here wow thanks for watching